you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with Pete
hes what's happening weirdos this is uh
Eddie if Eddie if who I uh only really
got to know the past couple months we we
ran into each other at the comedy store
and we were in The Green Room and I had
just the most effortless and hilarious
and fun and interesting conversation
with him then and just really vibed with
him and then I checked him out did a
deep dive which you should as well he's
got lots of comedy albums and specials
check him out on Spotify check out his
uh podcast which is called talking's Hit
like talking
[__] talking [__] um he's wonderful this
is one of those uh did we just become
Best Friends episodes and I'm so glad it
it was effortless like a classic like a
classic you made it weird so fun so
funny so interesting let's let's dive in
only a couple things to talk about up
top my special I am not for everyone is
available now on
netflix.com it's a website or an app the
support for that has been uh tremendous
and I'm so proud of it and I really hope
uh the weirdos like it there's a lot of
stuff in there that if you like this
podcast you'll probably like the special
uh I'd gu I guarantee
it I don't know how I'm you're going to
hold me to that guarantee but
anyway uh I'm also on tour go to P
homes.com I'll be in DC uh Brea
California and I believe uh what else
they're all on pom.com um this episode
is brought To Us by our friends at
element which I have right here of
course because I start every morning
with element what is it it's zero sugar
hydration it's the perfect blend of
sodium potassium and magnesium that gets
my neuroconnectivity jump started in the
morning replenishes everything that I'm
sweating out after I exercise and
honestly it's a great way to wind down
the day I have this is the chocolate
salt flavor I drink this hot at night
and something about it gives my body
what I lost during the day and it keeps
me from peeing at night I don't know
what's going on I I've heard that about
sodium but there's something about an
element before bed that keeps me in the
bed all night night this is zero sugar
it's 5 calories makes fasting really
really easy feels fantastic feels
wonderful to get your body what it needs
healthy hydration isn't just water it's
water plus electrolytes and element is
the most delicious fast efficient and
effective way to get that sodium
potassium and magnesium into you for
health performance and energy fight off
fatigue headaches brain fog it's
incredible tastes wonderful and and we
have a free sample pack which is awesome
because you want to try all these
flavors there's like a habanero one
which is strangely good like a spicy one
it's incredible so if you order with
this promo code go to drink lnt.com
weird and use promo code weird you'll
get the free element sample pack with
any order when you order that's lmnt so
drink LM nt.com weird promo code weird
and you'll get that free sample pack
trust me you're going to love it I
absolutely love it I'm a I'm a
subscriber and a Believer and was before
we started doing these ads so I'm so
happy to be working with them similar
situation is our friends at on it and
alpab brain you guys know since pretty
much the show's Inception I've been
taking Alpha Brain by on it 15 minutes
before I do anything that involves my
brain writing a script doing a podcast
uh doing stand up even just going out to
a party we went to a Halloween party
take a couple Alpha Brain before I get
there because if you want the full
access to your brain your memory your
creativity your focus your vocabulary
all of that stuff Alpha Brain is Earth
grown ingredients it's not a stimulant
it just gives your brain the nutrition
that it needs to dial in and focus and
to create even if it is just creating a
conversation with friends at a party but
if you are doing work like focusing work
God I wish I knew about alphab brain in
college it would have made things a lot
easier I'm so glad I know about it now
Go to
onnit.com
weird promo code weird 10% off it
changed my life no exaggeration Alpha
Brain changed my life I always have it
with me in my car in my bag in my coat
Pockets I swear by it it helps you dial
in it's not like it doesn't get you edgy
like caffeine it's not like that just
gives your brain it's like giving it
food like giving fish food to your ideas
so go to on it.com weird for 10% off
everything you see on that landing page
support your brain support the show all
right everybody let's enjoy Eddie e
together get into it take get that
microphone and tell tell everyone how
your wife is too good oh you're just
going right now are you yeah but we can
edit this out I always uh you want this
no I don't care you want to edit out
when I your wife no I can say anything
about my life is so transparent um I'm
an open book did you realize that the
show transparent was
transparent no
transparent it's like when you realize
the Beatles is be a t it's like a joke
on the beat and transparent was a
transparent oh did you know that I
didn't know that you're it's almost like
no like you know what I mean it's like
too perfect too easy too easy do you
know about the Mandela effect tell me
the Mandela oh was this simulation
theory that Mandela died in the in
prison but there's so many of them have
you ever gone over them all like magic
mirror on the wall barenstein bearss
yeah I don't I'll tell you I I love this
thank you for the Eddie brought a gift
let that let that be known yes to the
rest oh sorry your gifts are over there
this is modern R and this is Magic mind
if you want to drink it it's really
great is this the stuff the mushroom
stuff uh no that is not the first person
over there that's mushrooms anyway let's
let's talk about simulation Theory
because that's all for you um and thank
you for this
um I don't buy the baron stein bears
Baron stein bears you know I always
thought it was the baron stein bears of
course it was the baron stein bears and
I I know it's spelled stain but like
it's also Pirates of the Caribbean I
would have you know what I'm saying like
we just agreed I would have caught Baron
stain as a kid yeah stain that word
you're looking for every bad word do you
remember when you read in school and you
would turn words bad words how do you
even spell Ste I think you're just going
like I guess that's
pronounced the one that got speaking of
do you see turd in Saturday because if
you're not seeing turd and Saturday
simulation Theory just went out the
window I didn't see turd and Saturday t
r d so there you go pal how about this
one did you know um Queen the end of the
song We Are the Champions We Are the
Champion no time for good uh there's no
time for losing
it's not my friend yeah it is my friend
there is no my friend shut up I swear to
God We Are the Champions We Are the
Champions no time for
L there's no my friend at the end not at
the end but in the middle in the middle
there is but not at the end and
everybody sings it my friend but it's
not there but because it's in the middle
I'm all here I'm here for this no I'm
not I'm against it you are I'm against
it and I think that's why I think you've
heard it so many times that you just
keep saying it and misinformation like
well mirr on the wall That's the other
people say so for people that don't
understand what we're talking about
these are like uh what would you call
them Mass agreed mistakes like large
groups of people believe something wrong
right and people are like well that's
because they're not wrong it's kind of
funny when you say it like this it's
because we live in a simulation and
there was a glitch but like it's a
really fun feeling like a stomach droppy
sure the world is Magic kind of feeling
I want the World Magic I want all these
things to happen I want every conspiracy
theory to turn out to be right oh sure
but I know they're not I was just in
Utah and my opener was like God I hope
you're right like to be look I might not
be correct but this was how the the
latterday sa Mormon afterlife was
explained to me was you get your own
planet and your spirit wife and youp
populate it with Spirit babies and
that's kind of what God did here you get
to be a God but you do it by having
Celestial sex I was like I hope you're
right I hope you are blowing space loads
and I was like and Mormons don't have
hell if you don't believe you just
become one of their servants and I was
like I'll happily bring you a Monty
Cristo in between space loads are you
kidding me I would love that that's and
I'd be so happy I'd be like this is a
great job I bring snacks to this orgy
God but my problem with that is that
John Smith Joseph or Joseph Smith just
came up with this this was there was
there wasn't a lot of input from other
people I'm with you and look I don't
happen to believe that the story is true
but you're not wearing magical
Underpants I am but it's a it's a g
string with a vibrator on my butthole
and I'm that's the only way I cannot
come the problem is I'm actually always
coming I don't know if you know this
about me like I'm always just [__]
I'm wearing I'm wearing a garbage bag
could you imagine could you imagine if
that was your thing like that was I have
to stop myself from [__] just like I
I've had to learn kegle exercises to
stop from [__] I'm in a constant
orgasmic State some people are too sensy
right well that's why you keep the
foreskin the forkin helps you have sex
longer yeah no l if you have forkin
you're more sensitive covered and
protected all the time and then when it
comes out to
play yeah cuz I was just going to say
what is the evolutionary benefit of
having sex longer there's absolutely no
benefit in fact having sex quickly would
be rewarded evolutionarily because so I
I live outside of the city and people
sometimes are mauled by wolves and stuff
and it's always when they're peeing it's
like a biker will pull off to the side
of the road and take a leak and the and
animals know you know how your dog wants
you to watch it while it poops you know
everybody seems to have that joke that
the the dog like looks at you he's
saying watch me because I'm vulnerable
cuz I'm shaking and I'm squatting and
I'm you just made me feel like such a
hack because I do have that joke and I
was like not ack but it was one of those
ones I was like no one has this joke you
know when you think one everyone has it
no I don't know I think I've said it
before but I don't think it's hack I
have the joke because my father-in-law
hack judge my father-in-law my
father-in-law pooped in a neighbor's
lawn just pulled down his pants and
pooped in a neighbor's lawn why uh for
revenge or he really had to go he had to
go really badly and he just dropped his
drawer which means it was kind of loose
probably it wasn't nobody really needs
to let out a perfect poop but but he did
the look the dog look the the the look
at you real quick you just go it was
that you acknowledge it wasn't it was a
bag of Skittles it it
was but I mean he watched you to watch
him I but there had we had to lock eyes
there was this moment of well yeah also
look out for the neighbor I mean you
know what I mean like we have other
threats shame I thought he was going to
the neighbor's house to go knock on
their door like a normal human should
even that I was worried about him going
to a random neighbor and being like hey
can I come can you imagine someone
knocked on your door and like can I [__]
I need to come in your house and use
your there's a face that we all know how
to make but we don't know how to do it
on Q like I couldn't do it right now but
if I really had to [__] and you go into
a place where the bathroom feel it you
there's a face yeah like and it's only
for that and it's it's not just for when
you need a bathroom and it's an
employees only bathroom or whatever it's
a face that you make that says like I'm
really not kidding and I'm really it's a
subservient face it's a face that says I
yield to you that face doesn't always
work I never works I took that face
almost doesn't work I took that face
into a place I I forget get something
Pittsburgh Tavern or something on the
top of Mount Washington I would like to
know their name so I could trash them
yeah I took my daughter we were home in
Pittsburgh where I grew up and I had my
daughter and my son and my daughter is
like eight years old she's eight so it
was it was just recently wellow and um
there's nowhere to go at the top of
Mount Washington that overlooks
Pittsburgh and I'm like I'll take her to
the bar across the street wait this is
for her yes and I go in and it's a
restaurant like everybody's eating and I
gave the guy the look like she had the
look I had the daddy look like yeah we
need your bathroom please yeah and the
guy goes sorry can't use it he goes it's
for customers only and I was like okay
and he goes if you want to buy something
and it was a crowded restaurant and I
was like I'm dead inside right now
that's what I felt like it's one of
those things in those situations I
usually hand somebody too much money oh
just to [__] say [__] you you're like me
I'd go here's
$300 because [__] you that's why and I
hope I hope this buys something that
kills you yeah yeah go buy a motorcycle
go buy a three a $300 motorcycle will
definitely kill you go buy a crossbow
you [__] yes drive right into an
intersection today cuz to me the kid an
eight-year-old an eight-year-old even
I'm going to extend it up up until under
18 I'm going to say up until 16 the kid
all rules go out the window kid felt
like has to go I get it this isn't a
very touristy area where they probably
get a lot of requests but we both had
the look The look like this kid the look
to go and it was so disheartened my
daughter was just like like there are
father-in-law it and pooped it on the
lawn that actually would have been a
great idea and she should have done it
right there in the lobby and been like
can I buy my own [__] back how much for
my own [__] like she shits on the floor
and then goes how much for this does
this count as a purchase and if it does
I'd like a receipt I want you to type in
blue ink on white paper one human [__]
dot dot dot dot dot
$7 and please put a tip line cuz you're
getting a big tip you're getting a big
tip for dealing with this I'll tip 100%
you're getting 14
bucks I I had a guy [__] on my walk what
like I had a neighbor or not a neighbor
there was a guy um one I used to live
with Steve Burn I didn't know that I
love Steve years ago we lived in Venice
together we both moved to New York uh
together and we're living in this
Cottage in Venice like half a block from
the beach and one day I come home and uh
there's a guy under the house like he's
going under this little like this little
Hutch and I go hey uh excuse me what
what are you doing and he goes oh I uh
your your roommate said I could stay
here and I was like okay I was like and
Steve was always having guests so I was
like do you know what Steve was always
having guests did you say to one of them
they could live under the house it's
like you're really billy goat
gruff we're gonna let Billy go Gruff
live under the we had Joe doosa enough
now you're going with the now you're
going with see that's the perfect place
for Joe I say that with full love Joe
would be like I deserve this and it put
the great back down there's hogy rappers
everywhere I'm making sandwiches yeah
I'm making sand that's where Joey Rose's
sandwich shop was born under a
house so the guy's under the house and I
was like okay and every day I would come
back and he'd be gone or something and I
would give it a little look see what's
going on every day he was adding to the
it was like you know under a Venice
house wait did Steve say he could stay
in the cross I think Steve said I said
Steve did you tell this guy and Steve
goes oh I told him he could store some
stuff there or something and I went okay
and uh the guy the guy had one half
white mustache okay if you have half a
mustache you're going to have to go down
full mustache half of it was white oh it
full mustache and half was white so God
gave him a weird look
yes yes that that that okay I can live
the other way on that that terrified
anytime it's half I got Belle's poliy I
was like God did that to me my face well
it's a bit Yeah if it's only half it's a
bit that was God going I'm bored today
here some half your face you get it from
mold I think probably yeah probably from
mold new in New York no that's funny you
say that we had mold in our house in
Venice is that in the Steve house yeah
that explains Steve's act yeah I'm just
kidding I was just looking for a way to
work in's sandwich
wers cheese is mold cheese is mold
you're defend is cheese is
mold so by the way great sandwich have
you ever been to Jo Ros but I want to
it's actually really really good yeah
all right I couldn't see doing it unless
it I know you don't like to give Joe
compliments I'm completely joking but
but but if I do I'll say edit that out
it's really good okay so half mustache
under the house he starts to put shelves
beds mattresses uh he's running
electricity from our laundry to a cable
is Steve e like Jesus Christ or is he
just an idiot you know what I mean was
it like a move of compassion or was
honestly think a combination Steve is a
super generous guy he is yeah and I
think part of it was like I probably
would have let the guy
too but as he started to go remodel yeah
you know yeah yeah when we were watching
TV is that the Property Brothers down
there when when we were watching TV and
we heard boom boom boom can you keep it
down no shut the [__] up shut the
fuckor I was just giving a look to Katie
because I was like isn't it funny I said
the property brothers because Jonathan
Scott was on the show yesterday which
isar yeah which is clearly why you only
had one of them just one of them yeah
Drew and I have a beef I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding how did you only get
one I thought they're like the scars
they have to come together you know I've
always wanted to have just one of the
scars on as well you know why I think
that means a lot to twins I think that's
like that's like that's like watching
somebody when they poop on their
neighbors line it's like a real it's not
why I did it it's because I met Jonathan
in the wild uh twinless mhm uh so that's
how that happened but do they go away
from each other I think so but they lose
power it's like a Wi-Fi like The Amazing
Race they have to be able to see the
other one at all times you have to be
line of sight yeah I think so okay so
you're in your house and Steve Burn led
a half white mustache man yeah move in
downstairs he starts putting in shelving
and bedding shelving bedding candles uh
the you can't light a candle under the
house guy gas leak gas leak with
lighting candles so he's dead no he's
not dead then these construction guys
down the street come down they go hey
what's up with the guy under your house
and I said I don't know they said he's
you know he's got a new bicycle every
day and I went oh they're like he's like
a known bike thief in Venice and I was
like uhoh so then they said we think
known bike we think he stole our tools
and I was like okay they're like can we
go under your house I said sure why
don't you join you know what why not at
this point why not get under there yeah
there is room at the end so he goes
under and he's like here's all our tools
and I was like ah the guy's at so then I
say the guy's got to go so uh I tell the
guy go Hey listen man I understand you
stole some stuff blah blah blah you
chill like that yeah but he was a bit
aggressive like a
like a thief might be yeah like a
homeless Venice Thief would
be and uh Venice is a good flavor for
this story you to say like he told me he
was down on his lock and the first day
he was like sweeping my steps you just
didn't know he wasn't getting lucky
stealing stuff we had Craig gas live on
our couch for six months he was a way
better guest than Craig gas wow like
Craig gas yeah and isn't Craig gas sort
of famously wild is that what we're
implying I only know him a little yeah
Craig gas stayed for six months and gave
me a h sleeve of H chocolate chip cookie
dough that was the thank you that was it
six months wasn't a blanket you could do
and you're a gift person yeah and you're
like no I didn't care I just no I know
but when you give good good gifts it's
bad to get a SLE he just said to me he
goes hey uh he came home one day and my
girlfriend was with me at the time and
he goes hey do you like chocolate chip
cookie dough and I was like who doesn't
is there anyone in this world yeah we
all risk sell Manila for it any day and
then he goes cuz uh Ralph's had a two
for one so I got you one so he didn't
get you one Ralph's got you one ral's
got one don't tell me I know don't tell
me that comedians are lunatics so I got
this one free so it means nothing to me
so here you go comedians are not
talented they're disabled I agree and
you know what is another uh mental
illness fame fame is a mental illness
Fame is a detriment that that uh creates
a mental illness I like that
and I always am like careful you wish
for I have tiny tiny little teeny bit of
Fame in Australia and I get there in the
first two days I get there I'm like this
is awesome and day three I'm like how do
I get rid of this oh wow really what is
the how do I get rid of it
impulse when someone when I do dumb
things and people will be like I saw you
you're at if and I'm like
yeah yeah you just saw me do that you
saw me do surveillance while my
father-in-law took a dump on a lawn yeah
and I'm just like God why why do I why
did I ever want any of this when I was
younger I wanted it so badly can I say
that Sal Manilla is to cookie dough as
an unwanted pregnancy is to sex it's a
very good
analogy it's a very very good analogy so
you know what's interesting here's a
couple things
that I know about you one is you went
overseas and and got big there got big I
always say
like people I think it got overblown
like people would be like that was the
lore in Australia and I'm like I'm not I
was on a lot of TV shows but it was like
panel shows like the VH1 type stuff sure
but I mean they only have four channels
so at the time you're seeing him you're
seeing Eddie so I was on but I wasn't
like Arch Barker is a household name
yeah and
I would always be with arge and people
would be like arge Barker and you you
know it was like I was you yep
and if I you if I wasn't with arge a lot
of times they no one would know who I
was but because I was with arge they're
like oh other American comedian yeah
yeah but arge was gigantic what was the
play what was the who told you about
going overseas and were you frustrated
like what the [__] is with America oh
yeah yeah I what was that period of your
life by the way maybe you don't want to
talk can I say this talk about we're not
going to forget to talk about that I was
listening to your newest record on the
way in malabo Sweet Home Alabama Sweet
Home Alabama yeah and you're like so
talented you're really really good I
really appreciate that I really really
do and it's not just that you're killing
and you are but there you don't lull I
this is the same compliment I gave Sam J
but meaning I'm saying that because I
want you to know I mean it for both of
you it it's like running water it's
natural you know what I mean it's cuz I
talk a lot I could talk yeah but but the
themes are are tied together and you
standup can be so jarring like now we're
talking about this why and you're just
like somehow you tied it all I
appreciate that because I try but I also
feel like I watch guys like you and I
feel like you work really hard and are
really talented and then I go oh I suck
I'm a fraud I'm a charlatan I don't know
how I figured this out and we all feel
that way okay when you when I watch a
great comic just doing it doing the
craft it doesn't matter if it's Dave
Chappelle super famous or some I I don't
want to name someone not famous but
somebody not famous an open micer who's
doing it I'll still be like God damn it
you know what I mean they just like [__]
I had a show uh not that long ago where
I got up stage and I said to Matt who
tours with me I was like am I done you
know what I mean we're never that far
and he was like Pete listen to the tape
you killed sometimes you're so tired but
that's what makes it like golf I don't
play golf I hate golf I agree but golf I
played as a kid you hit that hole in one
and you go I could be a pro did I'm a
I'm a pro level I shot one shot into the
hole I should do this all the time
everybody should watch me and then
there's a day you go out and shoot 150
and you're like I'm done I can't believe
my parents kept me like they should
buddy I feel so seen I also use the same
analogy and after that show which was
great by the way it's just sometimes
you're so tired and vulnerable and like
tender and you've been doing too many
shows and you're doing the show and and
you're feeling something that isn't
happening except inside of you you know
what I'm saying you get off stage and
some of the I'm not going to lie some of
the lines I was like that just didn't
work and I'm like and that's like one of
my favorite jokes and it just didn't
work yeah and like it's a joke that like
works or doesn't work like there's a
point and a Twist and the twist is
revealed and everyone's like oh wor but
yes and I love what you're saying
because what happens and I'm getting
closer to being able to do this in real
time is you go this is what makes
standup something you can do your whole
life endlessly interesting and
compelling and meaning making
because you never know you might go up
and it might be kind of if it was all
always just home run Derbies you get
bored of that but a thing that I've kind
of programmed into my brain to make me
get through that is there are times when
I I used to sell merch a lot and after
the shows the nights that I would feel
like I didn't do so well yeah I would
sell the most merch and I don't know if
it's they felt sorry for me I'm G to say
it's not that or they were listeners and
the reason I say that is I don't laugh a
lot but I'll go oh that's funny that's
great I love that that's incredible I
like you'll hear me cackle when
something goes goes arai or something
shouldn't have happened or they say
something that the crowd doesn't laugh
at that I think is so and I want to show
the crowd like you're all dumb yeah you
eat you eat crab guts everyone else is
eating the claws and the like give me
the you're missing out on something so
funny I'm with you so I went to see John
Stewart once I used to have the same
manager as him and I was doing a show at
Acme in Minneapolis and my manager goes
hey you want to go see John I was like
I'm kind of at the same time but I'll go
watch like the first half of his show so
I went in and I'm like he got me like
great seats and I'm sitting right in the
front and it was you know nobody talks
about John's stand up that much but it
was one of the best I saw like the first
45 minutes it was like
one of the best sets of Comedy I've ever
seen I was blown away edit that out
and that
out he's had enough he's had enough
can't we instead start the lore that
he's
like I laughed twice I saw I laughed
twice he was like huh
huh and and I said to myself right then
I was like don't get mad when they're
not laughing yeah like but you know you
get that feel when you walk off and
somebody goes to you and you know you
had a bad set and they're like you were
great you were great and you're like no
I wasn't like I know yeah yeah but wait
how did the John Stewarts at tie were
they quiet at points no I was very you
were quiet I see so I was like don't get
mad at the audience when they're not
this is actually where you and I in my
opinion we had like a classic Comedy
Store Green Room hang where I felt
really close to you I think I even said
that I was like really close to you
right now we missed yeah we missed
that's exactly right you came in in the
generation of guys that just stormed the
business like the blitz cre were known I
you did there was a whole group of you
what if I meant that you mean the blitz
cre that's what we've been calling we
all we have a a thread we have a text
thread we met there's a guy called
Churchill the cre um you yeah we missed
each other I was in New York you which
year did you start in New York yeah I
moved were you Chicago first I was
Chicago from 2001 to 2004 then 2004 to
200 that's why we missed yeah because I
was New York from like 97 to about 2005
six yeah barely and I was and you
wouldn't have seen me then anyway
because it was open mics and stuff and I
was going to England a lot yeah and
so when I came in it was like nightmare
it was so mean New York can I say
nothing I just love that you're pointing
this out cuz it [__] was it was the
meanest thing it was so mean so mean
every conversation was something that
I'm like you know like like a gas it was
either mean or it was like something a
story a pirate would tell you know what
I mean and we stole their rum and you're
like J chist now I feel like that guy
that like I went through it I do too of
but I don't want anyone to ever have to
do that again me too dude it was me and
Nate baratti standing in a circle out
out front the Celler we weren't
performing there we just go and hang out
there and it's you know and these aren't
bad people I'm just saying they were
like yeah they are they're terrible
people there was a group of very bad
people there but but I look at them
like I look at them the way you look at
a pitbull in a shelter yeah that's great
they were abused they're talented that's
why they're talented because of the
abuse that was inflicted on them this is
good but they're going to bite you yeah
and they're going to bite your friends
can I tell you one that i' I've told
this before and it's Billy bur and we
love Billy bur but and there was a time
when I was just so tail between my legs
open my guy and I said something stupid
trying to be funny I hadn't I didn't
know how to be that level of confident
with like [__] all these greats all
these murderers and me and Nate and we'd
just keep our mouths shut and then I
said something it doesn't matter what it
was like yeah that's why Eddie's wearing
Navy CU they don't have Army blue or
something and they trounced on you worse
everyone was talking when I said it the
only one who heard me was Bill and Bill
goes he said and they were still talking
and and then he
waited and I watched him wait and he and
he was like he knew as soon as they stop
talking like the newspaper he's going to
tell them he said and he did and the
most emasculated is maybe not exactly
the right word but I felt really really
maybe neutered or just [__] oh I sad
waiting politely for Bill to introduce
the topic as you told me that
I could feel like it was like the trauma
coming it's trauma it is and and that's
why we're ritualistic ritualistically
reenacting childhood trauma I'm always
saying that but you have to get curious
about what is what is the pain that's
familiar to you and how does it attract
you to situations relationships people
friendships jobs that like help you feel
comfortably uncomfortable does that make
sense that makes total sense and then
when you get older you go so I'm not
doing that anymore and I'm not going to
do it to the young guys either no I'm
not going to I was in a fraternity in
college and they tried to Haze me and I
was kind of like No And they would they
would be like you they better do like
you're going to do and I was like no I'm
not you did the thing that I've always
wondered they're like in the last one J
on the cookie has to eat it first of
all I was just like the last one to jizz
on the cookie if you're doing that
[__] horrible I hope it's an urban
legend Okie
everyone jizz on the cie and you're the
last one to jizz on the cookie and you
have to eat it why would you still
jizz why would you be like oh man I'm
going to have to eat this cookie when
I'm done might as well put my own
special sauce on there at least it's a
little familiar maybe maybe m Are Over
overwhelm the other taste you
know I hope that's not real no so I when
I was in the fraternity and they would
do it and I would just go no I they and
they would
go okay okay cuz they really couldn't
and so then these are college kids yeah
then when I became an older brother
they'd be doing it and I'm like this is
ridiculous and they're like you're not
going to go to the and I'm like no and
and then I'd call pledges up to my room
and I'd be like they'd be like making do
things I'd go just sit here and watch TV
and they're like you mean what are you
going to do to us and I'm like I'm not
going to do anything hey hang out let's
have fun that's my f cuz that is I see
why you went from where we were to where
we went because because comedy is like a
frat it is and there are people that
believe in hazing and I'm not I think it
was just the seller I think the seller
was worse than anywhere and I I just
watched patrice's documentary because
somebody told me to see I haven't seen
it is there Patrice documentary there's
a petrice documentary and they get me in
it like they Hammer me again and it was
just like oh it's still happening he's
dead and they're still coming at me yeah
yeah yeah and it was actually funny but
I think it was Bur Norton told the story
but Jim Norton walked past stage one
time I was on at the cellar in front of
like six people and he just comes down
to go to the bathroom and he's as far as
me to the camera and he just you know
you have to like go straight in the room
and then you make that right he goes
GH he makes his patented sound and the
whole room hears it he just looks in my
face and goes g can goes to the bathroom
comes out of the bathroom looks at me
again and goes double g
he said it again so while he's peeing
he's like I'm GNA call it back yeah and
and I'm just on stage like I got to quit
this business that's why you know what I
was thinking there was a time around the
same time where I sat at a table with
Godfrey and I but this is different I
said something and I made him laugh and
like he was generous enough to actually
like engage and listen to me I made him
laugh so hard and I was like I a chance
like I don't really know what to make of
this cuz I also there's like a little
badge of honor that I wear on the inside
that I'm like I went through a tough
time and I'm reading uh I heard about it
from some somebody the codling of the
American mind or whatever it's
interesting I I don't know if that's a
controversial book I have to say this
now I don't know if that's like hate
speech I'm I just started but it's very
interesting and it's talking about like
how like negative experiences dis uh
other opinions that you disagree with
are really good for like sharpening you
up and and and I I just heard someone
talking about the Navy Seals and the
reason why the training is so difficult
is because they want like insane people
that like will go through anything to do
that makes sense and then I'm like but I
think we've seen something really
interesting with comedy is that like we
have a generation that isn't coming up
through knife fights not at all and
they're a lot of them are fabulous I
can't say everybody is but that's never
true I
see I'm going to disagree with you there
that they're not fabulous I'm a big fan
of Action Sports and because of the
internet like uh like skateboarding BMX
surfing didn't it used to be called
something
else not extreme sport extreme is like I
don't know that's I don't I think isn't
it funny that Tony Hawk looks like me a
little bit I get it we both have the
Hitler
haircut I was going to say he looks like
a guy who's so relaxed he's going to
fall asleep and he's like doing Loop to
Loops in a p he's so amazing he's so
he's like he's like 50 some years old he
can still do everything really yeah he
cannot he and Kelly Slater are both in
their 50s and are still I mean who's
Kelly Slater Kelly Slater is one of the
best Surfers in the whole world he's
surfing on the world Kelly Slater Kelly
sler at 50 he's going to be 52 this year
no kidding it's like it just makes me
feel like we can all live forever yeah
yeah yeah yeah wow that's incredible
back to this is important to me I say
this all the time the progression of all
those Sports is phenomenal because when
I was a little kid and I wrote a BMX
bike you'd read a magazine that came out
every month and you'd see the trick and
you'd have to kind of figure out how it
was done in the pictures and someday
meet someone that knew how to do it and
it would take it's an information a year
to learn it you're giving me mine is
video games but somebody that knows how
to do a move and you're like you know
how to do it exactly
the PN
um now with the internet they learn it
the next day and it's meaningless and so
they progress and they progress and they
progress and they progress I thought I
thought you going a different way I
thought you going to say because it's so
readily accessible The Thrill of the
pursuit is gone so the meaning is
drained and they don't learn it they do
learn it they learn it and then they
take it another step right like oh you
did one backflip I'm going to do two oh
you did two I'm going to do three I'm
going to put a Twist in my three I'm
going to put a one leg you know and they
do this amazing stuff in standup comedy
I thought that was going to happen I
thought because they all have access
when I was coming up and standup you had
like evening at The Improv or Caroline's
comedy I go to the library what would
you watch go to library just to read
books I'm just kidding some libraries
did have album and some libraries album
did have a VHS section and I remember I
found and once eBay came out I I mean
old eBay no buy it now you could only
bid all this [__] i' got Jerry Seinfeld
standup confidential have you seen that
special no it has sketches in it bro I
Jerry doing sketches it's all on YouTube
now I'm dying to see that now and I I
know the sketches as well as I know the
material because I watched that tape you
know not until I wore it out but I
watched it over and over but like it was
a treasure to me and now you could get
it on YouTube doesn't that that kind of
I think it would rob it I I mean I used
to take the train into downtown Boston
to find the one Tower Records that had a
comedy you'd have to call them so there
was a quest and there was more meaning
when you found it it was a big deal that
and it made it special it did make it
special and it made me more likely to
cherish it and when you cherish it you
watch it and you take it very seriously
and that's why you know every word of it
which now the information just goes
right in and right out well that's right
and I couldn't just change like just
sidebar what I do with my daughter what
I'm trying to do she watches TV we not a
zero screen family but what I try to do
is I go before we turn it on she won't
always do this but I go we can watch but
before we turn on what do we want to
watch and that's what we're going to
watch because like there's something
about the committing right right and if
she sees something else which she will
because that's how it's designed you're
like no we decideed we're going to watch
this that's a good idea I'm going to try
that with yeah because that's what we
should be doing with ourselves right you
know what I mean I'm kind of like that I
mean I will get caught in a scroll but
of course I don't want to lose this
train of thought cuz I really believe
yeah yeah no no no please I'm stoked to
hear you say what you're about to say
bar and Steen bear so the
comedians Nelson
Mandela come on magic mirror on the wall
the other one uh Luke I'm your
father what is it really I'm your
father he doesn't say
Luke I love it and how would you take
that quote and make it a a meme you'd
have to add Luke otherwise it just
sounds like you're saying I am your
father your father but I'm with you it's
interesting the way memory works okay so
back to this yeah we're gonna get there
um I can tell you're a podcast host and
I love
it I just have been thinking about this
so much lately this this
idea the comedians today get popular
through likes views everything so
they're constantly Buddha like the
Buddhist thing is always like like it's
about the intention not the outcome you
should be intention oriented not outcome
and I believe comedy is switched from
intention to outcome where I used to sit
around the clubs and we would all talk I
feel like we should take a four minute
silence just to that's really good what
you just said we've shifted from
intention to outcome it's like we're so
commercial so not about the art sell it
yeah sell it sell it make it make more
can I add to that that I know that there
are some YouTubers that think of the
title in the thumbnail first and then
reverse engineer the content because
they know people will click on it I've
talked I've had like really good social
media managers and they're like hey is
there any way you can get the punchline
and have it said in the first three
seconds because then it'll keep people
and we need to get them to stay
engagement and we need click baity
titles and we need this and I just go
you guys do this because it makes me
sick to my stomach yeah yeah I'm going
to stay I'm going to do do what I do
yeah I'll just give you you take my
Dropbox and do whatever you do with it
but I have to get out of this because
I'll I'll I'll quit the business I feel
you keep going so we've shifted from
intention to outcome so the comedians
today are more focused on uh on what
they're Mak and how they're going to
sell it and how they're going to get go
viral and be popular without doing the
hard work of creating the art yeah and I
I feel like I'm that old man and I
didn't want to be it but one night I was
at zany's last year in Chicago and I did
my show and after my show they had the
open m uh no I was at the is there one
in Vernon Hill yeah there is one in
Vernon Hill or there was oh I did the
one downtown yeah yeah and I went to get
food and I came back and I'm like I
haven't watched an open mic in a while
I'm gonna watch the open mic wow so you
know when you watch an open mic and you
see you always see like one or two
people that you're like oh oh like
that's amazing or this person's got it
or they're gonna dude I was in an open
mic everyone knows the story but I love
saying it and I saw someone say you ever
see a kid so fat he looks like he has a
job and I was like that's the greatest
joke I've ever heard in my
life and I can't help every time I see a
kid that's a little heavier I'm like he
looks like he has a job that's a great
observation cuz they look like little
men is really all he's saying but like
that yes so I'm with you so you see it
in like oh my god well I I don't I don't
want to mention any I don't know any of
the names but I didn't see anything no
name nobody did that nobody had anything
that like made me go oh so I went
upstairs because I like couldn't take it
anymore I went upstairs I'm meeting and
the all the comics are up there and I'm
listening to them Converse and they're
like what La mic do you use and they're
going I've been editing on Premiere but
I somebody's telling me I should use
Final Cut Pro and uh blah blah blah or
or uh whatever the the other one is and
they're like um you know but I was
thinking using two cameras and blah blah
blah and I'm listening to all this and
I'm just listening I'm listening I'm
listening I'm remembering and this is me
being the old man I'm remembering the
room going did you hear hedberg's joke
did you hear uh Geraldo did you hear
that bit Geraldo did I heard he did it
like this the other night he doesn't
always say that he adds this in and I
wrote this joke what do you think of
this what if I said this and then
somebody goes you can't say that because
so and so says that and it it was all
joke talk and now I'm hearing all angles
cameras uploads every single bit of and
I I went like this and I this is unlike
me but I went excuse me and I don't know
if any of them even knew I was the
headliner earlier or anything and I
didn't want to be like hey I'm I just
went I don't know if you guys I'm nobody
but I'm listening to all of you and I've
been doing this for like almost 30 years
and I go all I've heard you guys talk
about is the business side of the
business and I haven't heard any of you
talk about the art none of you and I go
it's really gross and I go you said that
I go it's gross Luke I am your father
and it's really gross and and I said and
and and it's just it's making me sick
it's funny cuz I can picture The Green
Room which is where I met Mitch edberg
by the way oh wow I need to hear that
story too I love a Mitch Hedberg me like
I can well he was very awkward wait
let's let's I want to we put a said you
put a pin in it's a there's a pin in
Hedberg I'm so with you want I want to
add to your story by the way I was just
at Wise Guys in Salt Lake and the owner
was like when you we have an open mic
and you look at the back and it looks
like it's a news conference it's
everybody has a has two phones two
cameras GoPros all this stuff filming I
say this as someone who came from open
mics that were terrible I'm not and I
didn't see the open m but you're filming
nothing and editing it yeah and putting
it up hoping that lightning strikes
right don't get me started on how
Instagram is ruining stand up people are
talking to the comedian more because all
we're posting are these [__] [__]
clips that aren't funny no crowd work is
for the live audience only what's your
name Eddie if if I have a better last
name why the [__] is that in my feed and
it's encouraging nice hat Y is that a
VCR hat the younger generation thinks
that's what they're supposed to do now
and crowds think that's what they're
supposed to do I just look the crowds
were great in Salt Lake but I noticed if
I said anything to anybody they were
like I'm going to be in the video
exactly I went you guys know bad 80 I
have a joke about how my parents are bad
80 and someone just goes no I'm like
that sometimes happens anyway but it's
happening more that people are like
here's my
time do crowds go to crowd open mics
where they work on their [__] [__] I
might say uh that's got to Hur you say
heyo we should do that as a j we should
be like hey we're having a crowd
practice yeah you guys want to come down
to the Improv we're going to practice
being crowd doing so funing crowd work I
don't want to sound like a turd but
every show I do is crowd practice for
you to sit there and be a crowd there's
your practice you know why the greater
good that's why some [__] is like this
helps the show it doesn't it doesn't and
it's not I'm not mad at you and look I'm
like you I'm the guy that's like I'd
like to shine well shine but you know
what you got to do before you shine
[__] polish your [__] balls well
that's what one of one of the kids said
to me one of the kids that night when I
said that goes you don't get it he goes
it's so hard to move up you've got to
have a viral video and it's the only way
you're going to get spots and get
recognized and I go I think you guys are
off I said I sat down there during your
open mic and I'm I'm not going to lie to
you if I saw something that I really
liked I would have told every club owner
in the country I go I go to clubs I'm
friends with the owners I would have
been like there's this kid in Chicago
you got to see him he's so amazing it it
it it and by the way I believe you and I
do similar things you know why it's not
even philanthropy it's the love it's the
wonderful flow of energy that we were
given and it's a privilege to give it
you know what I mean when you see
somebody new and you're like God not
only is it good for them and makes you
feel nice to do something good but put
all that aside it makes you look good
yeah oh yeah cuz's in the mix because
you're like a curator of good comedy and
you're helping comedy right and I
remember when I saw Gerard carmichel at
like a like a horrible J Davis show like
at some bar somewhere an hjds horrible J
Davis show some of J I got an hjds yeah
this was an hjds and I watched Gerard I
don't know anything about show oh my God
like it was like oh I see it yeah I see
this and that's a great feeling it's
like falling in non-romantic nonsexual
look yeah you're like someone's doing it
cuz here's I think what you're saying
too is there's nothing more impressive
than just incredible standup comedy oh
and to reduce it to a Girls Gone Wild
video where it's like that's what it is
we've oh I I had a moment and look I
want to be very clear I understand
comedians posting crowdwork videos I'm
very lucky that I have a lot of content
and I can do that and if I didn't would
I be posting little riff and mo yeah
probably probably yeah if that's the way
the systems I love our people and I'm
just going
like be a Jedi be a [__] surprise get
really good you know like uh inside Len
Davis you know that movie
yes he goes uh you never release your
old [__] it ruins Mystique he like
that's right you know what I mean it's
like it's so
exciting not to now I sound like an old
man but the reason I went to Chicago for
as part of it was it was like this great
incubation there was there wasn't a lot
of scene there it's different now but
like I wanted to be a little Anonymous
and that was that's what Gaffigan and
Burr and all these guys told me then you
go to New York and I was already three
years good that's and you go to an open
mic where everyone's 3 weeks good and
your three years good now you you get
book shows somebody told me uh you're
only new Once don't let them see your
Growing Pains only one CH one chance to
make a first impression that sort of
thing we're in that business there are
clubs that if they see you suck they'll
never that's the way the [__] brain
works it's a pattern recognition
[__] machine I've had one of the
biggest guys in the business on the
industry side who used to be somewhere
else saw me have a horrible set and it
has followed my career like he just
keeps getting in more and more important
positions and everywhere he goes I'm
like I'm out there he's the guy I'm out
there and I'm like told my manager I'm
like can we buy him a vacation so that
he will watch me a new Association like
yeah like how do we break that pattern
but you're you're absolutely right and I
saw Louie say to young people in a talk
Scandal noted that's what I like to say
um Scandal noted and I saw him
say I Scandal noted it's the it's the
least timec consuming way to say like I
understand that that's sort of like an
inciting person um but I saw him say to
young people just opt out like I see
people uh booking clubs because they
have 70,000 Instagram followers and yeah
we will let you work and dude I hate to
admit this there have been people that
asked to do the podcast so I'm I'm a
[__] at times in that way too and I go
yeah right and I'm like holy [__]
yeah same here same because that's the
[__] gross I'm embarrassed to admit
that I don't do it all the time and
that's the gross capitalistic model that
we're all kind of stuck in but Louis
saying opt out we have to feed our
children that's what I'm saying yeah so
the the middle way of this I'm like do
both you know maybe post some
clips uh but just be careful you know
what I mean
you can't also you also can't reinvent
yourself like when Demitri Martin
started I don't know if he was doing his
style no he wasn't I started kind of
with Demetri we were good friends we we
wrote a film together oh no way yeah
which one it's not the one about no we
never we never finished it we never it
was it was a funny film it was about a a
a renegade marching band it was about a
marching band that uh it was the
quarterback gets kicked off the football
team because the coach is cheating and
he's a good saxophone player and so he
goes into into the band because it's the
only way he can keep his scholarship and
he's a stud and they're all nerds and he
doesn't like that they're being [__] on
so he kind of has them revolt and it's
based on the Stanford marching band
which is have you ever seen anything
about the Stanford marching no oh watch
the documentaries it's the most amazing
thing ever really they were like they
were like the coolest Geeks ever
everever mean oh they had like a band
house that was like a frat house kind of
thing and they would dress up they would
torture other teams they would um they
like when rean had cancer they they made
a nose on the field like with a tumor on
the nose and then out of their shape you
know how they all inform formation and
then they had like a scalpel come in and
cut the tumor off and they were just you
know really smart creative people can I
I want to because this movie didn't
didn't exist I want when you said
Renegade marching bin you know what I
really wanted was some situation where a
high school is taken over and the
marching band kill Like Toy Soldiers
kills the terrorists with their
instruments that's where I was
going just for that sort of like Get Out
moment where someone shoves a flute
through someone's neck it's like really
grotesque I I'm on a high school chat
with my seven best friends from high
school and we talk 20 times a day and uh
they buy lottery tickets now and it
drives me nuts cuz they talk about it
and I won't buy and they did on me all
day long about it and they said what are
you doing you should be out buying a
lottery ticket I said I'm writing a film
about a group of guys that all buy
lottery tickets and one guy doesn't buy
them and they hit and they get billions
of dollars and they won't share it with
them and so he murders them one by
one that's fantastic do you want to know
my lottery movie yeah I win the lottery
let's say it's me and you I win the
lottery and I'm worried that I will lose
all relatability as a comedian so I
don't want to claim it so let's say
you're my brother you're not a comedian
I give you the ticket I ask you to claim
it so you can be in the pictures and
everything and then you abscond with the
money and then I have to like find you
and murder you with with a flute though
is this the life of Dan cook it is
similar to Dane you know when Dane did
my pot I was like oh yeah your your
brother-in-law stole like a million
dollars and he goes 10 million said 10
that's what he said I I think I'm
remembering that correctly it's so much
more money than you think oh my God
isn't that terrible and you know the
story is they're in jail they know where
the money is and they're just writing
out their sentence so when they get out
they can go get the upy But if I was Dan
I'd just have the best private
investigator following him everywhere I
think we all know there's going to be a
guy in a super finger t-shirt in an
idling Chrysler in front of the prison
and he's he's
gonna I I picture a Trans Am okay a
Trans Am a trans yeah with uh aviators
and um no those aridium yeah yeah yeah
those are the ones I was trying to think
that are back in style yeah yeah I
picture him okay go back to how uh the
young people stink I I interjected by
saying the the open mic is like a press
confence got it you summed it up and
that's the that's the oh and I didn't
stick the landing on the Louie thing
because I'd like to know I want to talk
about that middle way thing he's like
just don't do it just become incredible
that's kind of what we're saying that's
what they all I mean uh my old man that
I love this guy James Dixon you ever
hear of baby doll um that's what he went
by everybody calls him baby doll um even
John Stewart John they all call the guy
they used to manage John Jimmy Kimmel
John Stewart Steven coar he had
everybody I know the Snowman Frosty the
showman no that's an agent okay well
this guy he just used to say to me be
undeniable just be and that's what bar
cat that's the advice that I got from
Jim gavagan yeah they just they got it
from baby doll Barry said it Barry cat
said it a lot um just be undeniable yeah
hey man trying be undeniable but uh they
ignore you until they can't I actually
saw that on a
T-shirt and I was like [__] every you
know Broken Clock broken t-shirt I was
like that's that's right a little side
Berry story yeah I always listen to his
podcast and he always says if you have a
problem with
someone in this business make up with
them Reach Out The Olive Branch make
friends with them it's not it's just
it's not worth it blah blah blah and
Barry and I had a beef so I call him he
lives out near where I live we meet up
for coffee and I was like Hey Barry I
listen to your podcast and you were
saying and I you know that you should
clear up your differences and I said I
just want to apologize if there was any
bad blood between us and he goes I don't
know what you're talking about
man I thought about
Barry
yesterday because I did Barry's pod this
is that I'll count heard your Barry
podcast maybe because I really liked his
podcast I liked it doing it I thought it
was really fun but one of the things
that I remember from the ber Cats
episode that conversation we had and I
was thrilled because he's you know he's
in comedian he like a legend and I was
like oh this great so I was very and I
have all respect for him so it was just
a something that really stuck with me it
might be a generational difference but
my wife and I yesterday were planning a
vacation just a little trip and I was
like I always think of Barry saying
don't worry about I I might be getting
this wrong but he's like don't worry
about like spending time with your kids
and like dropping them off at school and
stuff they don't remember any of that
they only remember vacations and I was
like what is this thought system what is
this yeah what what just happened look
he might not feel that way anymore but I
was like I
couldn't disagree more yeah me too it's
only the rides to school I do remember
vacations a lot yeah horrible hornets
nests of being stuck with people yeah
yeah no I I had a I always like to say I
had a pretty good this is where I always
felt like I didn't fit into comedy I had
a I had a very good upbringing like I
love my parents love my siblings I love
your parents thank you and um and they
love you they always
tell my mom lo my mom's past but my mom
loves loved Dean
Edwards nice she would always say to me
she saw him live she saw him live he
talked to her yeah and he's handsome
handsome and he's the nicest person in
the world and he would call her mom he's
like how's Mom how's Mom and he saw her
a few times and and she's like he and my
mom's like this you know little white
lady from Pittsburgh that's like oh
she's like I love that guy with the big
yeah you know the afro she's like he's
my favorite and she just loved him
because he was just she and it wasn't
even the comedy it was just of course he
was just so nice to her what I like
about I like a lot of things about that
story uh and it kind of brings me back
to what I was saying about The Comedy
Store we don't know I love what you said
about don't don't freak out if they're
quiet they might just be listening
that's something Val my wife says to me
too cuz I'll get off and I'll be like
what was that and she's like Pete
sometimes they're just they're running
out of Ste steam like it might not be
the bit and it might not be you like
stop taking it so personally and that's
what you said we were talking do you
remember the exact context it was like I
got mad I didn't let it out but I did
get mad at some way that someone said
something or ruined a bit or
something I don't even I don't that
night yeah I don't remember what it was
it doesn't matter what what what it was
it was I felt something that made me
uncomfortable and I was taking it very
personally and you were like this is why
I read The Four Agreements and I I've
been rereading The Four Agreements since
we saw each other it works for comedy
doesn't it we'll talk about that a
little bit I mean I would you mind
because I realized I was getting in a
trap before you get to The Four
Agreements eart toally tells this story
about the the monk with sweaty Palms
have you heard about the monk with
sweaty palms no but I have sweaty Palms
all the time so I feel like the monk it
might be the monk with shaky hands I
also have clamy hands I have a bit about
it I can put out candle without licking
it um
but see you got to know your audience
I'm like if you have sweaty hands I'm
ready it's hyperhydrosis is that what
it's called it's called hyperhydrosis
and I had it as a k sounds like
something Gatorade would claim and I
grew up really Catholic and would go to
church every single Sunday and I was an
altar boy and everything and the part
where they go the Peace of the Lord be
with you always and also with you and
then they go uh hand of peace or
whatever when you shake hands with the
people next to you I was like
yeah and so the fist bump is a gift to
hydro
hydr and it's only when I'm nervous and
church knowing that it was coming yeah
it got to the point when I was old
enough my family would all be in the Pew
together and I would just go see you
yeah
how time to bathroom bathroom break for
Eddie yeah Irish Catholic goodbye and I
I would just head to the bathroom and
then come back and I'd be like fine and
my sisters would look at me and they go
are your hands getting sweaty yeah and I
was like just stop stop no I I relate
hard to that in college was the their
Peak sweatiness and that was every I was
only I was friends with mostly girls and
they were all they were like sisters now
that I look back I never had a sister
but in college I just had this like
gaggle of lady friends and they would
like tease me mercilessly about my swey
hands and they were like I remember one
of them said with good intentions they
were like and you'll find someone
someone who doesn't even mind your
sweaty hands and she wasn't wasn't even
trying to be funny and you know what my
bit was and isn't this a comedian I'd
go I I don't even remember I somehow
linked it to virility to like I'm like
so charged not even Jizzy cuz I was such
a sweetie I wouldn't have said that but
I would I was I somehow found a way to
be like it's because I'm emanating so
much fluid I can't even do it now I
don't know how I did it but what was I
saying oh the monk with shaky hands is
there was a monk who uh believed himself
to be enlightened and he was going to
give a talk for like 500 monks and he's
backstage what's on his rider like a
Gong I'm just kidding we just riffing
what's on your Rider [__] vegetarian
F okay uh and he noticed he's about to
go on stage and his hands are shaking
he's nervous so he left he walked into
the woods like you and he didn't
uh returned to society until he had
actually reached Enlightenment this is
probably a myth at this point uh but the
reason why he realized he wasn't fully
cooked as I like to say like he hadn't
reached realization was because he was
nervous because he was like if I know
it's all one and I'm just talking to
myself or like it's not real or however
you want to phrase this why would I be
nervous to like be in a dream where I'm
just giving a talk like who cares like
you see the monks that were at
shandling's funeral and they're going up
after the greats yeah Bob Saget murders
for 40 minutes and now trunp you know
like this guy I saw the footage and I
was like these cats are the real deal
they were not monks with shaky hands
they followed you and I would be like I
can't follow professional Comedians and
they go up they don't do comedy they sit
in a temple and they kill and they're
calm and they're steady and they're just
just in this way that you're just like
oh you can't fake that and I like that
nerves as an indication that I've
forgotten that you're me like if I was
nervous talking to you it would be
because millions of reasons but like one
way I can calm myself is I'm just like
I'm just kind of talking to myself it's
just like a dream and we're each these
localized things let's not get too deep
but you see what I'm saying no I do see
if I can get in touch with Oneness
anxiety goes
away Parton the interruption weirdos
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at armra you guys know I'm
always on the lookout for ways to
strengthen immunity gut health improve
my fitness my metabolism recovery
enhance Hair Skin Radiance well I
recently discovered I don't know how I
was in the dark on colostrum but armra
colostrum I just discovered this
thousands of five-star reviews from
life-changing testimonials from users
what is it colostrum is the First
Nutrition we receive in life and
contains all of the essential essential
nutrients our bodies need in order to
thrive and it turns out we can
supplement this which is really cool
armra colostrum is a proprietary
concentrate of Bine colostrum that
harnesses over 400 living bioactive
nutrients that rebuild the barriers of
your body and fuel cellular health for a
host of researched back health benefits
it strengthens immunity ignites
metabolism and
anti-inflammation fortifies gut health
activates hair growth and skin Radiance
Powers Fitness recovery and performance
and confers Powerful anti-aging benefits
I mean that's insane how did I not know
about this armra is premium B Vine
colostrum concentrate and unlike any
other products on the market it is
wholly natural sustainable and was
developed with the highest Integrity
from start to finish since I've been
taking it I'm noticing all sorts of
benefits hair skin glowing feeling that
Radiance from inside gut health you know
and everything that goes along with that
is improved metabolism been feeling
great in that regard and working out I
get you know I'm 44 I get sore muscles
sore shoulders especially this is
helping in my performance in Fitness and
super important my recovery I've also
noticed that this is the season that
kids are bringing home colds and stuff
old homes over here I'm rocking it just
fine
supporting your immune system comes down
so much to supplementation and armor is
making a huge difference we've worked
out a special offer for my audience
receive 15% off your first order go to
try armra AR
rm.com weird or enter weird to get 15%
off your first order that's try armra t
y a RM
a.com weird and
get it in you support your body and
support this show speaking of support we
can also be supporting the Earth with
our friends at Blue land did you know
that an estimated 5 billion plastic hand
soap and cleaning bottles are thrown
away each year 5 billion and if that's
not bad enough most cleaning formulas
are 90% water this makes no sense it's
heavy to ship leads to excessive carbon
Emissions on the trucks hauling them
around the country plus those products
are often filled with nasty ingredients
like chlorine chlorine excuse me
chlorine and ammonia I combine the two
into chlorine that's a lose lose
situation for you and the planet and it
doesn't have to be this way we don't
need water to be shipped around blueland
is here to fix this they're on a mission
to eliminate single-use plastic by
Reinventing cleaning Essentials to be
better for you and the planet their idea
is simple they offer endlessly fillable
refillable cleaning products with a
beautiful cohesive design which looks
looks great on your counter that's
actually kind of the hook that we got
into it we saw it at someone else's
house the clean white bottles and the
mission took it over the top we were a
blue land fam just fill your bottles
with your own water that you have in
your house drop in the tablets and wait
for them to dissolve you'll never even
have to grab bulky Cleaning Supplies on
your grocery run and refill start at
just
$2.25 you can even set up a subscription
or buy in bulk for additional savings
from cleaning sprays to hand soap toilet
bowl cleaner and laundry t
all blue land products are made with
clean ingredients you can feel good
about and you'll be doing something
wonderful for the planet and save some
bread blueland has a special offer for
weirdos right now get 15% off your first
order by going to blueland.com
ymiw like you made it weird ymiw you
won't want to miss this blueland.com
ymiw for 15% off that's blueland.com
ymiw 15% off all right everybody let's
get back to Eddie
if yeah well that's uh that's Flow State
that's uh totally I don't want to get
all metaphysical but I I was listening
like that we are the only beings that
actually suffer from our past and our
future like we get we we have we we have
anxiety of the future and we have pain
from the past where most animals live in
the now yeah and if we could get to the
now which is getting to the now is what
this this this was somebody was
explaining death to me and they were
saying that's what death is is like
you're almost in this like complete like
when you meditate and there's nothing
and that
nothingness we observe the universe our
whole life and then when we die we are
the universe yeah and so it's like you
are God you are Universe are God you you
you become you I'm tired of talk I'm so
excited to talk about this oh so you
become God you become the universe and
it's like when we achieve that and so
like the monks are the closest thing to
that because they've figured out how to
get to that where they don't have the
anxiety or the yeah because the river
ran back into the ocean yeah the thing
that I was going to very excited to tell
you I always mention rert Spyro I think
he's incredible and he talks about how
this Consciousness without an object
meaning a sense of awareness but nowhere
to point it and you could say death is
like that you just become awareness
itself and what's interesting I was
doing this on the ride down I was kind
of listening to yach rock and just kind
of being aware and it was absolute Bliss
and you notice that your awareness
actually isn't neutral it seems neutral
when you are first getting into it kind
of exploring it but you actually start
to recognize that it has attributes this
like knowing presence that's looking at
your eyes and listening out your ears
and all that stuff it itself is peaceful
and you could even use words like is
Happy is like fulfilled because it's one
it's not it's separate so we like it
okay that's a nice idea but let's talk
about the exploration of that idea and
he would say every night we go to bed
and in deep sleep like your deepest
sleep not dreaming nothing you're just
gone um he would say that's not the
absence of awareness that's the
awareness of absence so it's pure
knowing but there's nothing to know and
that's kind of like death and he goes
but we don't dread going to sleep at
night no we're not afraid to go toep
he go you look forward going to sleep at
night because when you are unencumbered
and naked and I I'm not thinking about
like this morning I woke up and you know
that feeling where it just oh that thing
I was worried about when I went to sleep
like re latches to me and I go [__]
because it was so nice being asleep sure
and and further evidence to his point if
it was the absence of awareness we would
close our eyes and then would wake up
and it's the morning and I'm not not
saying that doesn't happen sometimes
that that's sometimes how our brain
narrativized the experience but we all
know it felt like how long it felt like
it felt like 10 hours weird question
have you ever had a
colonoscopy am I about to get
one I'd love to there's a camera on this
microphone I had my colonoscopy and they
gave me propol which is the the drug
that killed Michael Jackson um it says
that on the Bott that's the way the
doctor sold it to me she goes you have
two choices you can do propol which is
what killed Michael Jackson or we can
give you fenel which killed everybody
else I me dark joke but thank God you
didn't go into sales I go this is uh and
I said I don't like to be put into a
deep sleep I've done it for a couple
surgeries wisdom teeth I go I don't I
don't want that and she goes I think you
do and I was like why not she's like
because fentanyl you're not really out
you're kind of there and there's going
to be a bunch of guys playing in your
butthole and I was like okay let's uh
did she say playing in your butthole
that's exactly those were her words who
is this doctor
yeah you have to go to like did she live
under your house in
Venice you have to go to this initial
meeting I didn't finish that story we'll
get back to that oh yeah um oh yeah but
so anyway I took the propil which is
kind of weird and when they gave it to
me they're like you're out in three
three two one boom you're just watching
the credits of your life executive
producer Eddie and everyone said to me
they go you are going to have the best
nap of your life it's like this sleep
and it's not it's
dark light you are like out and you're
out it's not like sleep it's not like
you know you're gone it's the closest
thing I think dead yeah dead and I think
it's because you wake up and you're like
well what is Life Time Travel it's very
time Trel life is the is exper is
awareness plus time right so we can tell
a story sure and you were experiencing
cuz i' I've smoked 5 Meo DMT and that
also is eternal
and timeless it was it was nothing what
I'm saying is we're talking about
eternity you experienced I I don't know
what you experienced I'm wondering if
you experience close to the Eternal and
the Eternal eternity doesn't mean
endless time like wow we've been in
heaven a long time it means the absence
of time that's what I do that's my fear
of death is that and I have huge fear of
death I'm going to a therapist right now
because I have a thing called
cleithrophobia and it's a fear of being
trapped and I can't write that's why you
don't wear a wedding ring it's exactly
why yeah and um your bit made me go I
started going like yeah I can come on
mine's actually very loose this is like
my third one I've lost it in lakes and
stuff did you see Jimmy Fallon's finger
yeah
but I'm not doing a lot of falling in my
kitchen I'm not trying to say anything
I'm not trying to say anything Jake this
is not the clip this is for listeners of
the PO only no In fairness I could fall
in my kitchen I saw a guy who jumped on
a a bar to swing and the ring Just DE
gloved it it's called de gloving for
anybody I don't don't which is what
killed Michael
Jackson
I was just thinking Katie we haven't had
like a really big podcast with a bit
emerges from the
conversation don't anybody Google de
gloving do not do it do I'm telling you
it's one of the most horrific things
you'll ever see and it's why I can't
wear a ring but no but it I feel trapped
I can't I get it my dad doesn't didn't
wear one either roller coaster bar yeah
over
me you feel S as a bug I used to love
them used to love roller coasters I
sleep
belt could you imagine on an airplane
that'd be great on an
airplane the airplane I let out all the
slacks so that I could slide out but
that's not safe Eddie I don't care I'm I
it says high and tight across your lap
and the nearest exit may be behind you
you you've got that every time I think
this I
go it does it's not worth it go but I
it's so I can slide out if I need to
yeah I don't like bathrooms with uh with
window but I'm fixing it I'm really
working you don't like bathrooms with
Windows you can't go out of no if it
doesn't have a window oh you just want a
window yeah I need to be able to break
out you know all I'm feeling is
everything you're saying is completely
valid which is what my therapist used to
say he goes paranoia is correct we just
have to get over it right you know what
I'm saying so we can validate all of
that I just my biggest feeling right now
is I wish you could experience the
snugness of like the
good constraints you know what I'm
saying like that's something that you're
it's like when people are allergic to
peanuts I'm like oh Thai food you know
when you're saying this I'm not thinking
what a weirdo I'm thinking like oh like
a little like secret closet where you go
in and read your Comics like you don't
get that no
it's we're I'm doing this thing called
EMDR yeah I know EMDR and uh but explain
it a little bit it's it's like a
bilateral uh you move your eyes in
different ways yeah you move your eyes
or or they you can wear headphones with
beeping or hold buzzers that buzz buzz
and basically the the woman that that uh
founded it discovered she was working
with like PTSD patients and that um she
had cancer and when she would walk
through the woods don't tell the
marching
band they do it for non-celebrities that
doesn't seem okay here they come the
field that's how your doctor tells you
they played a song called get it out too
oh my God took the um anyway she figured
out that when she would walk her eyes
were moving side to side and at the end
of the Walk The Fear would be gone but
it's it's about like your fears you know
starting your lyic system and they move
up and when we're young when all the
trauma is formed we don't have the our
brain's not fully formed uh in the
frontal L to uh kind of work those fears
out and so they stay stuck kind of in
our brain and this rewires it it sounds
very similar to EFT have you heard of
EFT yeah yeah I think it's very tapping
is that the tapping but it it also has
like a you look this way you look that
way I think it's almost the same thing I
think it's very similar and CU she does
fingers like you can do EFT for those
emotional Freedom technique which sounds
so stupid which is why we call it EFT
but like that's one of those things I
file under like why don't I do that more
yeah you know what I mean like it works
I mean one session I didn't even do a
session I just talked to her and I was
like feel so much better ready yeah and
on to like I get I get and this is to
work on what I don't ride
elevators and it's my sister lived on
the 15th story in New York City and I
used to stay with
her I had a class at the University of
Pittsburgh on the 42nd Floor you walked
up I just didn't
go
no elevator I show up for the final and
the professor went well it's nice to
meet you wow and I was like well I just
climbed Everest to get to you yeah I'm
not normally this wet that's it's more
than my hand so it's inconveniencing
your life yeah at this point and it's
you know what got me is my kids are old
enough now that they're starting to make
fun of me uhhuh and I realize I can't be
a good father because I've got to make
them feel safe right and if I don't feel
safe then they won't feel safe and so I
really need to fix this like quickly
because they're like my four-year-old
son's going come on dad you're going to
ride the elevator with me he's like
you'll be okay wow and I'm like do you
no I was just in Vegas all last week and
I refused to ride the elevator then I
got to get a security guard to take me
up each time come back and get and then
I feel even more trapped and yeah so I
was like this is this is this has been
too long
it's interesting I think all of these
issues it's interesting to here's what I
would ask you want hear something crazy
I do San Jose Improv have you ever
played there they have a hotel that all
the comics stay and it's like right
across the street and when I went they
had to get a security guard to take me
out my room and you go like through the
banquet room down the hallway around
this up here up this stairwell and I'm
always embarrassed when the security
guards take me and I said hey uh sorry
you got to do this I go do you do this a
lot you know with people that don't
write he goes no you know like you're
the only freak and then he goes ah he's
like we're the he didn't know that I was
the comedian he goes we're the hotel for
the comedians he's like weirdly a whole
bunch of
comedians no I went really and so I
don't want to name them but he named me
a bunch of
Comedians and uh you know it turns out
that uh Patrice O'Neal didn't I'm just
kidding um I was
what are the names I'll tell you all
fair yeah I got it I've known more I
don't have it as much as I used to but
when I was in college I had a real shy
bladder and I think it's similar here's
why it's an overthinking sure disorder
sure and comedians are overthinkers the
reason I mention that and I also won't
name names but I never met more shy
bladders than comedians of my style
meaning I don't think Jim Norton has a
shy plan you know what I mean I don't
think Dane Cook has a shy BL but if you
know a guy who's talking about his
feelings and stuff especially when I was
again it's not a thing anymore I'm so
grateful but I remember bonding with
other Comics being like I'll walk like
this is New York I'll walk four blocks
because I know there's a one-seater at
the village underground because I just
don't want to what happens is you're at
a urinal and you're like they're peeing
I'm not peing do they know I'm not being
it's just it's just it's actually not
shy bladder disorder it's overthinking
and a little bit of narcissism like
they're looking at me they're noticing
me and like it's like when you're having
sex like what happens if I can't get a
boner that's also not an issueing all
overthinking it's all overthinking stuff
you'd be like well now I'm flaccid
because I kept thinking yeah well that's
the worst thing that could happen here's
what I was going to put to you though I
got curious about how far will I go to
be special unconsciously speaking do I
kind of like like losing a boner is a
better example do I want to lose a boner
so she'll treat me special in some way I
us said it was in one of the Batman
videos I go one of the sexiest things a
woman can do is forgive right and that
was based on my life at that time was I
I can't remember if I was with Val but
let's say I was and we're having sex
we're new and it's not happening and
she'd understand she'd be like it's fine
it's don't worry about it and then I'd
be like completely into her because she
saw me and not only saw me but she saw
me as special so that's what I was going
to ask you accus I wonder that I've
wondered is this me becoming quirky
because I remember years ago I I went on
a tour with Bert ker and Ben Glee and
Bert goes I said can I get a room on the
first floor the hotel and Bert goes why
do you want to be on the first floor I
go I don't like to ride elevators he's
like why don't you like to ride
elevators and I said uh because I'm
afraid I'll get stuck in there he goes
oh are you are you afraid it's going to
fall or are you afraid and I go no I'm
just afraid I'll have no one to talk to
wow and and then you'll
vanish yeah I mean that is it it's like
that's why they have that call Button
hey but I catastrophized I'm like that
button doesn't work yeah uh there's a
tornado outside it killed everybody good
thing you know you catastrophized no
that's great that's a huge step and I'm
like I can create this scenario and my
friends a th and I talk to her all the
time it's like friends she's like yeah
you've got a creative brain and you
start creating these like your superow
it's just your spiderbite hurting
instead of giving you w crawling
abilities just a gross infected spider
bite yeah yeah and you have to deal with
it because you also like crawling on
buildings and stuff I feel the same way
it's like in situations I can
catastrophize it's not I wouldn't call
it a problem but it's because I write
stories I just told you a story about
winning the lottery giving the ticket to
my brother and then he abcon with it
because that's my job you know what I
mean but when like these things start
making it awkward for you and your
children or
whatever one of the things I don't like
about that is for you feeling your your
pain is I'm like I don't like the shame
element of it I wish it wasn't shame
motivated I kind of laughed at you know
being a comedian I you know I think
that's what we do we we find a way to
make our embarrassing issues and
problems comedy and then it's like ha
always I always called it eight Ming you
know how in uh in does Eminem would
always go hey I grew up in a what are
you going to do I'm from the trailer
park yeah what are you gonna get me with
now I call it Punky Brewster because
there was a heavy girl and she was
friends with Punky and she would always
make jokes about how at the time we
would say fat she would make all these
fat jokes and then at the end of the
very special episode they were like why
are you always doing that and she's like
if I do it first you can't do it and I
was at home going
like just crying sweet tears cuz I ate
so many
Twizzlers just sugar
tears but yeah but that's s yeah that's
and I think that's what we do as Comics
so control the narrative yes you say it
first yeah yeah so but part of me was
like have I created this um but I think
it's some trauma and I've got to figure
it's funny I was telling this woman I
was like I don't have any real trauma in
my life I go Ive never had and I start
telling her stuff about my family she's
like and she's like I I think we've got
enough yeah she's like we've got she's
like what you perceive as trauma she's
like you have lots yeah this is this is
it what you just said is it is like we
need to Greenlight our goals and our
dreams and believe in ourselves you also
have to believe in yourself in the other
direction and go this is what I just
figured out I'm just figuring this out
my wife is a genius at this stuff and
she and having someone validate and go
like that was trauma that you
experienced trauma it doesn't have to be
karate kid kids with ghost makeup
chasing you on bikes that did happen to
me though I mean it happened to all of
us that movie was a
plague it did not oh God yeah it did oh
my God what oh my go-to it doesn't have
to be that did happen to you yeah chased
by kids on bikes oh [__] yeah what oh
yeah I came home one day on the school
bus and the school bus would let me out
about a hundred yards from my driveway
I'll do the
sound and there's a I'm in eighth grade
the junior high and there's a bunch of
high school kids with their car waiting
with baseball bats at my stop for me and
I see them and I'm like I'll get the
next one I'm going to die and I was like
and and I go I don't know what to do and
one of my friends Nina katza said to me
just stay on the bus and go to my house
yeah and I was like genius so the bus
starts moving and they all jump in their
car to follow us and I realize nah lives
like a mile from her bus stop you've
just given them a lot more terrain to
chase you yes and I'm like you went from
a walkway to your house to Nina's and I
was like I'm dead I'm dead so he's just
about the bus driver's at my driveway
he's gone like a 100 yards and I go stop
the bus and he's like stop the bus and I
he stops and I come running up and he's
got his hand on the door and I go open
the door open the door and I was a bit
of a Mischief maker as a child and the
bus driver knows that there's a bunch of
kids with baseball bats chasing me he
looks at me and goes are you going to be
good are you going to be good from now
on I go I
promise
he saw his opportunity to negotiate yeah
I'll be a model student I'll be a model
bus rider and he goes and he opens the
door and I fly out yes with them all
chasing me out of their car and run in
and slam my door and and how did they
pick you they had a these guys they they
had a fort in the woods that was the
most amazing Fort you could ever see it
looked like something from like a uh
like apocalypse
yeah sort of they built out of they cut
down trees and I grew up in Pittsburgh
in this little suburb of Pittsburgh and
down by this in the woods we live in a
very wooded area they cut all these
trees down themselves and built Forts
and they were high school kids and they
would build like cabins almost some of
them were two stories some of them they
had a creek that went under one of them
and they had a whole little village and
they would all go there and have parties
I hate this
well they were kind of I don't want to
be there they were kind of nerdy kids
okay they weren't the cool kids they
weren't and the cool kids want once and
trashed their whole Fort now I like them
a little
more but they they were always drinking
down there Les and they had alcohol
there and somehow the alcohol was stolen
and I had a little tree fort in my in my
yard it ended up on the top of my tree
fort the booze so they assumed I stole
it I would love it if you did steal it
but that's still how you tell the story
like a mafia guy and let's just say that
alcohol ended up on the top of my tree
for okay I don't know how it got there
it fell off a truck and I'm like I think
they were getting there there was a
there was a cousin of
Joy's but whoever stole the booze Carl
Kel Carl Kel Carl creel was one of them
and took it and planted it on me
creble
creble and he planted it on me now cut
to I'm friends with all those guys
creble not so much
creble wait you're friends with the wood
boys the the guys with the bats that
were chasing me but they I okay look I
still hate that they were chasing you
with bats but at least there was some
hey that's the guy that took our yeah
I'm guessing the plastic bottles of
vodka and know it was a like it was like
a case of beer or something that they
were going to kill me over but you know
a case of beer is important when you're
16 years old I mean good Lord yeah they
all these stories like I don't know like
what if they caught you they would have
hit you with bats I don't know because
the one one of them I'm really really
close with now he's one of my best
friends yeah and he's like I don't even
know why I was there he's like they were
telling me I had to beat you up and they
were all like you've gota and he's like
I was there to fight you and he goes I
don't know why but I was just peer
pressured into and he's like the most
passive guy in the whole world I don't
think he's ever been in a fist fight in
his life he's like I was ready to kill
you I know in high school a lot of
people are just pretending that they
have been in fights pretending
everything pretending you've kissed
somebody or whatever I don't think they
do it anymore though I don't think they
do any well it's been
shomiz you know what I mean and I mean
that in the good way yeah Timothy shalam
made it like cool to just be like what
like uh that simpsons's joke nice PJs to
Bart Nelson says nice PJs your mom get
you for get them for you and he goes
yeah yeah it's Eminem that's the shaming
the mizing of just like yeah I'm not
[__] like why would I pretend to be [__]
but I think in the 80s you know what
else was happening my my nephew does
that to me he's he's 17 and I'll go are
you are you really going to wear that
out and he'll go yeah and I'm just like
you got me yeah got me again and I'll be
like o That's nerdy and he goes yes it
is you know and he just owns everything
fig yeah yeah can't get him at all ever
I love that yeah it was dinguses like us
that hoped Bill bur would be sweet to us
that kid would be like he wouldn't be in
the circle no we were only in the circle
because we were from the 80s yeah and
we're like this is normal I you know
it's so funny a friend of mine that's a
comedian that kind of came up with me we
always talk about that like why did we
keep going back there because we were
ritualistically reenacting our childhood
traumas like we're like that's so
interesting you can be my abusive family
I'm not saying my family was an abusive
family I'm saying this is familiar
tension
yeah the the irregularity of like but it
was worse it was worse than anything I
had experienc when I was a little kid it
was physical with all like cousins and
neighbors and we were grew up in like a
it was a very well a fluent area but it
was it was Irish Catholic a lot of like
fights my dad always hey you get in a
fight you don't start it you end it
never start a fight end every fight you
know like that's how I was raised grab a
bottle yeah yeah grab a bottle and break
it somebody comes after you you do what
you got to do you know like and yeah and
so very tough kids and very lots of
sports and lots of I think my dad was
tough and then like I we just weren't we
were I want to say nancing about I I
know if you can say that well then your
mom did a good job what do you mean like
taking that out because I see that
happened with my wife's family my my
wife's yeah my mom did do a good
protecting us from like you don't have
to teach your son have you seen the
movie Black Mass no Johnny Depp plays uh
Whitey Bulger there's a moment where
he's basically telling his son like if
you do something and nobody sees it did
you do it and he thinks he's doing right
by his kid like teaching him how to
cheat and steal kill kill or be killed
sort of stuff and there is a certain
amount I I don't know what the amount is
but we used to think it was 70 PBS and
now I think it might be a thimble of
like look out for yourself you know like
you know what I'm saying no I don't it
used to be like somebody's giving you a
[__] in the school yard you go up and
break his legs you know and now it's
like have some awareness of who might
not be safe you know it's like more like
that yeah and and I I know because I
always talk to my children the way
the books say I always I I say I'm the
Book of Mormon well my whole life is I
go to Instagram University and uh
there's good stuff on there so much good
stuff I always want to say I read but I
feel like going I scrolled and saw I
have a bit about isn't it funny that
when we say I read somewhere we all know
you mean Tik Tok I was reading really in
your study with little reading glasses
on your nose can't Rize were you taking
a dump looking at Instagram is that what
it was yeah that's so funny and I hate I
hate that you just did that cuz you did
what you did what Chris Rock's done a
million times where I have an idea and
it's so unformulated but I know there's
something funny in it and then you see
someone do it succinctly and you go [__]
I know [__] you captured something that
needs to be talked about and just got it
in that yeah yeah and then it's first to
Market who's going to film it first but
it's also like but if it's it's on like
Chris does that a lot he finds it where
no one else finds it like we all kind of
knew it but no one knew that it could
possibly be done can I run something by
you sure I think so that idea was in the
marketplace what Young and all those
people the collective unconscious that
all creative people are kind of like
sending their kites into the storm
clouds we pull it back and we have the
idea and sometimes there's an idea for a
movie that just is in the unconscious
because we're getting all the same input
and stuff I think one of the greatest
evidences for that being real meaning
like there just are these ideas and we
kind of fish for them and then when
they're caught they kind of become less
I I'm this isn't necessarily literally
100% real but just hear me out they
almost become less available it's like
I've got it and it's here's here's what
I'm trying to rationalize how many
comedians are doing a new hour every
year or two and how much parallel
thought is there so much I was going to
say not that much oh I think there's so
much there should be way more is what
I'm saying I think I'm so scared to look
I'm so scared to look at like if I'm
doing a bit Yeah I won't look either but
then when my special drops I should be
getting all these like that was on this
that was on I will say there's a lot on
my new special there's a a bit I do
about prove you're not a robot that
seems to be a premise that I saw or
Adams do a bit about it uh I somebody
said hey you should watch melen a bit
about that just to make sure it's not
the same which I did and it's not but
there are topics that float around but I
mean
like we really should be seeing like the
exact same observation more it like and
I try and I strive like I wrote this
joke and I was using it as an example of
like no one could possibly have this J
joke um I have a bit about taking my
dogs to Rattlesnake aversion training
yeah I think you're in a unique space
because it was so funny I should um do
you know Chuck Martin no Chuck Martin
was the director of Arrested Development
he opens for Seinfeld a lot and he hangs
out at the Improv he used to hang out at
the Improv bar all the time he's kind of
like Cliff at the bar you know like Jee
Pomo was norm and he's cliff and the two
of them are hilarious they just make fun
of each other and I walk in one night
and it's just like sitting down and
cheers and he goes hey what's up you
know I'm like hey he's like what'd you
do today you know and I go
I went to Rattlesnake version training
for my dogs and he goes I hope you're
going to open with
that and sometimes you need someone from
the outside I remember
going oh yeah like that's a really
unique and I had a whole story about it
and then I thought about it I'm like if
there's any other comedian in the world
that went to Rattlesnake aversion
training with their dog yeah they're
gonna have a bit too because right it's
just too for I agree i' I've made this
before in the crashing writers room Greg
Fitz Simmons was saying someone and I I
I've talked about this with Greg I'm not
talking can you tell me who was in that
room who all well it was it rotated so
much it really did did it yeah Jud did
an interesting thing where he would do
like four week stints with a certain
room and then would funnel it down it
was it was interesting and uh it wasn't
I don't I can't say but I imagine it
wasn't necessarily the best for the
people that were being rotated out yeah
I don't know yeah that would kind of
suck but it's not so yeah but but then a
core group as long as they knew coming
in though that it was only that's true
that's true and then by the end the room
had solidified more but I'm trying it
was like Beth Stelling Mike Lawrence
Solomon Georgia I'm trying to think of
other it was a great room yeah but uh
Greg and Greg Greg fit Simmons was one
of incredible he's awesome but we had
this kind of friendly debate where he
was like somebody stole my wishing
fountain joke and we were like and I was
like don't tell me what the bit is but
is it about like and we kind of got to
it like we have so much water we waste
it in fountains like is that it and it
was yeah and and he added to it and we
even throw money in it like it's it's
double wasteful and I was like I just
feel like that's there that is the joke
I had a version it's not nearly as funny
but I was like there I saw this was back
in my Open Mic days I saw Glade made an
air freshener made with real fruit this
is I'm so desperate for material I'm
like I'm going to do something on that
and I'm like I love that people are and
I'm also very Seinfeld at the time and I
like made with real fruit I love that
people are starving but I just took a
dump you know what I mean it's like
someone could have eaten the fruit but I
just took a [__] yeah we got a we got a
situation it's like real Fruit so it's
fine but meaning that category of joke
and I'm really interested in the
marketplace of jokes I really feel like
you could watch it like a stock market
like right now we're seeing a huge Spike
and managers and agents are like stock
Traders and they go to where the money
is and right now the money is in Like
Comics who are talking [__] I've seen
like way more I don't mean talking [__]
like haters I mean like if you're in
this world where you're not supposed to
say certain things and you're saying
them anyway I've seen a Spike oh yeah
that's of the the backlash to the PC Mo
it's the backlash and it's and now it's
popular it's it's an NW UA record with a
explicit lyrics there's more money to be
made if you're up there saying this this
and this and that's a thrill and it's
entertaining and it's delightful and it
has a bigger Market than people even
anticipate but I think that's really
interesting to watch and similar like
you said the PC movement there was a
time well oh now this is going to spike
this is but there's also topics that
Spike and things that come around it
would be nice and I think with AI we
probably will be a track it easily
because they saying they're going to
start throwing podcasting into AI where
it's sourcing from AI once they get
Podcast once they get everything in it
and that's kind of I mean this could be
a whole other podcast but it's it's
going to make it disgusting what do you
you mean like disgustingly powerful well
it's I mean that's why I thought going
back to standup that I thought standup
would get better and progress oh yeah
finish your point because we well I did
kind of finish it
but remember when you used to say
something and you'd go I need like three
examples mhm and so you'd sit all day
and try to think of examples now you
just go on chat GPT and go give me 20
examples of blah blah blah and it's like
oh I'll use this one this one this one
boom throw those in so you're like there
that joke's done time to move on I've
done that I've gone on chat GPD and said
give me an example of something that
seems like it would be a good idea but
it ends up not being a like it has to be
more specific than that and it'll give
you 19 garbage ones and one pretty good
one right and so I would think the
progression of standup would be just
incredible but it's not it sucks you'd
think we'd be getting stronger
pessimistic well I also think about who
the best stand-ups are right now they're
all in their 40s and 50s yeah because
they've developed and they've developed
and and it didn't always used to be like
that Eddie Murphy was 18 years old yeah
and now it's like you're watching these
guys in their 50s that are just crushing
it I I yeah I was just talking to B
bigley about that like CU well I won't
tell you why because it was self-
serving but we were talking about how we
all getting fun here let's just say that
it was like yeah cuz you're in your
probably doing your best stuff that's
what it was yeah he was like this this
is the best special you've done and it's
because you're 44 right I was like right
yeah that makes sense but what's
interesting I don't know if my daughter
will it could go one of two ways one
it's like a throwback in the way that
people still like watching VHS tapes
today like because it's fun MH and
people love stand up and it and it
becomes more interesting more human
Maybe or I think it's probably the
smarter money is like it just won't
exist in 50 years because I don't think
what is standup except like someone with
a special skill to remember and deliver
adapt and and
engage but you are remembering you like
studied something and if that is no
longer that interesting like why
remember some what I'm saying is I don't
know if my daughter is going to know
memorize in stuff very interesting point
like and it won't be a have you seen the
thing where the people wear have you
seen this yet I'll send you the video
this guy created this thing and it like
goes on his bone here and comes down and
he they can ask him a question a htic
Jew is that what we're talking is that
what that's a culture I I didn't curl
he's got this and he and he has a little
piece of the talmid in a
thing like I'm what if I really thought
that's what you meant you mean an
orthodox hidic if I was acidic I would
do this move every day oh yeah I'd
accentuate points with it I think that's
my
SE yeah use it use it or lose it as they
say I don't know what that means that
would be my tagline use it or lose it
that would be my get or done yeah or the
um what's it called teim the the strings
from your oh that they wear from your
belt don't know those are pretty cool
I'm I'm not even doing a bit I think
they look cool I forget what I was
talking about uh the guy had a thing in
his jawline and oh yeah and he would
they would ask him a question like
what's the capital of Kenya or something
and he would think it yeah I read well
that's what's happening next is mind
reading yeah and it would Google for him
and in his brain this thing would then
tell and he would have the answer it
would hear the answer or it would be in
his brain in his brain the answer would
show up in his brain the answer would
show up in his brain like his brain was
taking it in he would then send it out
to this device that was connecting
mentally yeah like you get over there
yeah kind of go to the device and then
he would have the answer well that's
what I'm saying if this is happening now
yeah and my daughter will be entering I
hate the term the workforce it sounds
like Stalin or something now she shall
be one of the cogs but like that was the
wrong accent but if that's our already
kind of
happening if I heard Joe Rogan say like
we're in the Atari version of that and
like we'll be in the Xbox version of it
um I think people are going to watch
movies from our time and see us in
University lecture Halls just listening
and going like and writing it down it
actually is [__] like what is this
1691 oh you write down something they
know and write it down in the hopes that
you can be disciplined enough to cramp
into your brain and now we're just going
like no just put it in your brain my
daughter's school her principal is this
new principle that they've brought in
and his whole concept is this like
growth mindset that like why waste the
time with the things that aren't going
to exist so don't make them have to do
those yeah cursive is one of the things
I remember I was at a school meeting
this are they going to learn curs of
yeah and and I guy dress like Mozart are
they going to learn cursive pray tell
please not cursive where you shake a
little salt on it afterwards so the ink
dries is that what it shall be no get
the [__] out of here the person asked
they were like um are they going to
learn cursive and the teacher was like I
don't want to answer this and and the
teacher was like well we haven't really
found it necessary and I was about to be
like what the [__] and then I was like
yeah it really is a waste buddy it's
return addresses on envelopes it's
signing a check it's all gone but here's
the good news it doesn't matter what you
learn you're learning how to learn
that's what they that's what they would
say right the growth mindset is learning
how to be creative because there's
always going to be a need for creativity
yeah and learning how to learn my my
daughter's in a monastery school and
they're teaching her how to learn it
doesn't matter if it's sewing a little
thing or pouring some water from into a
glass she's learning how to learn and
that was always my defense of learning
algebra and all these things you're not
going to need it well you're Lear
learning how to learn that's all you're
doing and and I wish don't you defend
Algebra I hate don't you defend it I
know but I think it's going to be
interesting to talk about a Marketplace
of ideas and beliefs and what's valued
if one of the things and I really think
this is sort of pulling the curtain back
is like how do you remember all those
words how does a standup go up and like
seamlessly do an hour of talking if
that's no longer
interesting uh something else will
become interesting true and it'll evolve
yeah crowd work um and it'll be just
crowd work can I hear your Mitch edberg
story you can and then you're going to
finish here under the under the porch
store deal and you'll tell you'll tell
your Mitch I'll I'll tell my Mitch you
tell your Mitch then you tell your porch
mine's not that exciting mine's not
exciting at all but I just love he was
smoking a
pipe how could you say this is
exciting he was smoking like a
gentleman's I know I did not picture him
with a
no it was a regular like a Sherlock
Holmes pipe well I don't know Pete yeah
well I was side of his mouth you hear it
I think Godfrey smokes a pipe you know
it smells great I've smoked a pipe it
doesn't taste like it smells you know
what I'm saying my grandfather did every
once in a while was it did he have the
pipe that was like this or was it corn
cop I think it was more corn cob but
dark wood because Zan's downtown is next
to that really great tocaria okay you
know that one
the old town no I don't know doesn't
matter but um I wasn't even working I
went and saw him I like you know that
one opposed to the other one the old
tocaria it's next to an apothecary
they'll blood let you and sell you a
cigar I would love I think cigar smoking
is so stupid just do nicotine having
blood bling is
funny I I don't know why we're bringing
carbon monoxide into our nicotine
consumption any who a Wile can we act
like we're smoking a pipe while we I
where was I in Utah I walked by a bar
and there was a young hipster smoking a
pipe and I was like times of changeed
they always go
like it's not cool you know what's
cool cigarettes work letting it in and
exhaling it like a dragon not sorry was
your soup too hot that's the same
thing it's not a
cool if you have
to puck and pop it's not a cool tobacco
experience so Mitch yeah Mitch
was and we had just watched him I part
of the story is what I remember from his
set too because there were bits that he
not even bits but yeah it was a bit he
talked about on stage how he couldn't
sell a TV show and I remember this bit
because I I think the logic of it is so
bad that's what made it stand out he
goes people in La won't give me a show
because they don't think I can entertain
people for 30 minutes but I'm like every
night I do 45 minutes that's like a TV
show and a half right and I'm sitting
like but it's completely different you
know what I mean I'm just kind of like
and it didn't really work he was just
trying something new but that stood out
and then after the show my wife at the
time uh came up with me and uh I'm also
I'm just remember I think Dwayne Kennedy
opened and he murdered your wife was a
comic no no no she she was came up with
me it's like no she came upstairs with
me okay and this is not a scandal but
Mitch very awkwardly I was like um and
he goes who are you to my wife I said
like whatever I said gave him a real wet
sandwich handshake he's like gross your
hand is so clammy but I've never seen a
clam say to another clam man you're like
a young man's hand doesn't go the other
way sand is like a million little rocks
but
I just I just want to do that sounds
like a bit it does right I'm going at
channeling other people's voices um here
we go I go this is my wife he goes who
are you I go this is my wife and he goes
if she's your wife why is she up here
kind of like a But like everyone knew
he' not like sending groupies up he was
with his wife at the time but he made
like an awkward like and you could tell
he felt weird that he said it he was
like he almost basically with his body
language was like why did I say that you
know but he did say
like why is a we never got to see Mitch
do this yeah I know and I think if we
had gotten to this we would have found
out that Mitch was who Mitch was because
there's probably a lot of social phobia
and a lot of like oh yeah he was awkward
yeah and and we never got to see this or
he could be awkward just like all of us
could be awkward he looked so cool
that's right but it was probably just a
front for how uncool he felt I watched
an early set of his and I was like
before he had really figured out out
that pace and stuff and I was like he
his dorkiness and I say this as a dorky
guy I'm like was very clear to me he was
just sort of
like you know a lot of his
bits aren't hip it was like how he did
oh sure and and a lot of his bits said
by anyone else are not funny yeah I
remember being in an open m and a guy
had clearly just remember when every
19th comic was just doing Mitch yeah
yeah yeah and he went up on stage and
this is this bit this bit is coming back
from 15 people saw it and now I'm going
to do it for a lot of people but he goes
like this he goes this is not Mitch
Hedberg this is a guy ripping Mitch
Hedberg style he goes it's so bad I
dated a woman with no thumbs already I
hate it I didn't know she had no thumbs
until we went hitchhiking that [__]
went
nowhere you liked it you liked it he
liked it he liked
it he liked
it that bit went nowhere you know what I
gave Mitch a joke once I didn't hate it
as I said it I gave Mitch a joke and he
looked at me like okay man thank you and
meanwhile I know he was like I will
never use that joke yeah what was it I
said uh I like to wear
camouflage um because I'm afraid of war
and that way if there's a war I could
hide in an Army Navy Surplus store
that's I like that I thought it was like
I wrote it for me and then I was like
it's not funny I'm going to make it a
oneliner though the best place to hide
with camouflage is an Army Navy sore
better way more to sing but it's your
premise I wrote a joke that was very
much like Mitch I probably told it on
the podcast before but he goes I'm G to
tell it like Mitch but I didn't but it
was the same words I go I was in my
apartment and there was a moth and I was
going to kill it but my friend said
don't otherwise a giant moth might come
by and kill you so I spared it now I'm
afraid a giant moth is going to come by
and thank
me want to give me a big Dusty hug hang
out by the light bulb sometime I don't
need any more
friends the the last part of it is where
you really you need it you Channel Mitch
oh I definitely Channel you also need it
it there's like a real curve to that
where it's like it's interesting jokes
it's like I don't need any more friends
it's not worth it it's not worth it it
is worth it like sandwiches sandwiches
sandwiches are like a story that starts
with bread and there's a call back at
the end my story about medium is not
that exciting John Bush do you know John
Bush he was a New York New York Comic he
was from Minneapolis he I guess was
friends with Mitch way back in the day
back there from I think Mitch was
originally a Minnesota comic or was he
SE anyway he comes to New York and he's
like he's in the comic strip where we
all kind of hung out there almost as
much or more than the seller at the time
and he's like do you know who this is'
and I said 'no he said' this is Mitch
edberg because he's really funny and I
was like okay he like we're going to go
play darts across the street you want to
come and I said yeah so we're playing
darts and Mitch was really nice he's
like Hello nice to meet you and I was
like he's like uh and I was like hey
Mitch I heard you really funny or
whatever and he's like oh cool man
thanks and I look down and he's wearing
tree torn tennis do you remember tree
torns no tree TNS they kind actually
kind of looked like this but they had a
little upside down V and the only people
that wore them like beorn Borg the
tennis player okay and it was mostly
women wore them at like country clubs in
tennis and I
go and it's like I I had nothing to say
to him and I just go tree torns and he
goes yeah I like them they're real
comfy they're real comfy and but it was
like he was wearing like a woman's shoe
yeah because it was he didn't care yeah
what anybody thought he was like they're
a comfy and then I saw him one night say
the funniest thing on stage at the
Boston Comedy Club he was bombing so
badly yeah wow and everyone did it was
impossible unless you you know that's
where I came up I never thought of him
on that stage so hard and he he's
bombing and he goes well okay I guess
that will be it for me I will be leaving
and the crowd starts doing like this
like
you know like clapping kind of like good
yeah next comic and they all start doing
the CLA he goes no no stick to your guns
you did not like me wow and it was just
right there I went that was like
brilliant how he you know no comic would
say so that's like our worst our lowest
moment we know we've just bombed we want
to get out of there and we just want to
like shower this off our body yeah and
he said something so funny and leaving
no stop you did not like me Demitri
Martin back to where we were earlier he
went up at the Boston he used to bomb
there a lot and he he didn't do well but
no one did and I I'll never forget it
because I was bombing probably 20 Comics
after him at like 1 in the morning but
he went my stink was on the stage but
yes yeah it was just just there you
could feel it yes like a Mist but
Demitri in the middle of his set he was
doing fine but it wasn't going well he
goes I can tell I'm not your cup of
tea like he just called it out I know
that's not it's not as good as your
Mitch story but I had just never seen
someone acknowledge like comfortably
yeah I know I'm not for you that's okay
because I'm like if you're not for them
you deserve to die you know you've got
to think about demetrius's confidence
though I know he dropped out of law
school after two years yeah just I I was
like to me maybe you should just finish
you know it's just one more year just
get it done man yeah and he was like no
I got this yeah yeah he knew very and I
was like and I knew how funny he was I
was like enamored of him but he he
wasn't doing well and I was like are you
sure like like you really you're making
me realize what was significant about
that story was he was one of my favorite
he is one of my favorites but at that
time idolizing this guy he bombed where
I was bombing something gavagan told me
when I was starting he was like we both
kind of had a rough set in Germantown
Wisconsin and he goes there's some
crowds you don't want to do well for and
I was like what like I just never I
thought it was supposed to be a home run
derby but really there's a com if you
bomb with in front of people who just
don't have a taste for what you're going
for yeah you can show There Will Be
Blood to somebody and they'll be like
that was boring if I did a
good if I did a show on the capital
steps on January
6th I'm pretty sure you'd bomb well you
can't say bomb you would not do
well you would do
poorly I just said that at the airport
no go ahead you used the word no no I
didn't use the word but my I only travel
with a a backpack if anyone who sees me
somebody came to my show twice in Utah
I'm like if you're wondering why I'm
wearing the same shirt it's cuz I just
want to travel with a backpack the I
don't give a [__] who the [__] is going
to be like did you wear the same shirt I
don't care care I want to travel so
lightly get out of my house as quickly
as possible it's a go as quickly as
possible it's still packed Eddie it's
still packed I don't unpack it I mean I
take the dirty laundry somebody told me
to keep one in your car just keep I have
a go bag in my do and that's when you
gave me your wife's blanket I was like
this is going in the car yeah cuz I've
been in situations where it gets cold
I'm like if we broke down we'd need some
blankets so I'll be thing of you as I'm
dying I'm dying slightly slower because
of this thin lagona Beach Blanket I'm
just kidding um what was I saying it
doesn't matter uh the crowd that uh you
want a bomb for you want a bomb for we
still have to talk about the poop oh
yeah thank you so the bag thank you
Katie is stuffed not horribly but if you
open it it's going to Spring open and
stuff is going to fall out it's gonna
spring open like a parachute basically
and they and I got randomly selected
because I had an apple in my bag that
got me flagged anyway so the TSA agent
who I'm always like I don't know if
you're this way it's like when you give
too much money to the guy that won't let
you use the bathroom I'm so nice to the
TSA especially if they're kind of Curt
with me I'm like overly like anyway so
they're opening the bag and I go careful
it's it's really full it's going to
explode oh oh my and we both just let it
slide a I go careful it's really full
it's going to explode but it did explode
with socks and stuff yeah it's like a
prank I'm the same way though it's so
funny you do that um yeah okay so the
guy pooped on my
steps I kicked him out of the house and
I said you're GNA have to leave and he
said uh I need to talk to the landlord
and I go I am your landlord and I go you
have to go you've stolen this stuff so
he wouldn't leave and I said look it was
like a couple days I go going give you a
couple more I got to get a truck I I go
look
after a couple days of I go look we're
putting a padlock on there on Friday you
have to have your stuff out by noon on
Friday he's like okay so he I see him
unloading he shouldered me one time on
the way out and he would just give me
these dirty looks wouldn't talk to me I
mean I can kind of see how he got to the
place where he is in life like you know
when like he's not a chill hang no he's
just a very oppositional person that
that I saw it come out and I was like oh
this is yeah you know you have you
struggle in life and I was still trying
to be like nice to this guy because I
felt bad about but you can't steal stuff
and keep it under my
house I feel like that's a good line so
he
leaves I come home that night and there
is a giant steamy human [__] on right in
front of my door it's funny how you know
a human [__] I mean you look at several
times a day yes but the thing I thought
about it I wasn't that mad I kind of
laughed
I knew I was going to have to get a
shovel and like pick it up and throw
which is going to be like piz those
things they slide pizzas into ovens you
go and then put it in an oven crisp
it but I
thought it was probably worse for him
like I'm
a yeah his was a uncomfortable with his
dis and you're squatting Squat and your
dick gets compressed into this like like
you're hover
your qus are tightening and doesn't want
to hit his pants and he's just sitting
there and I thought you know what you
idiot you won
yeah what a thrill Eddie thank you for
doing this this is so much fun so much
fun
effortless uh we'll talk about it some
other time so people call my comedy
effortless effortless well I did say it
flows effortless we have the guest say
keep it crispy at the end it's just the
sign off and I'm just pointing because
it says it on that sign but you you get
all this stuff we have similar hair
types you'll like the modern mammals you
should take the magic mind with you and
you'll get some first person what is
this a game show I'm just saying that's
don't forget it can't wait to read
Misfit and you can read an advanced
unproved copy of Misfit by Gary Gman is
that an un really that's un proof
there's no typos in it though it's
[__] garyo
yeah everything's perfect yeah it's
perfect um it's it's I'm seeing Gary
it's
perfect um that's that's a good G
perfect uh I can see it okay um would
you grace us with the keep it crispy and
thank you for being here keep it crispy
and thanks for being here very good very
good and see why I don't act I drive to
your house and poop on the lawn just for
that would would be funny if someday
Steve Burn's like I'm the one that took
the [__] it was me his dying words Eddie
it was me you made it you made it you
made it win oh yeah you made it win you
made it wi you made it win oh yeah you
made it you made it you made it oh yeah
you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah